[Music]
everyone welcome back to eyes on
enterprise where I bring in Googlers to
talk about the technology landscapes
that are shaping how enterprises adapt
modernize and scale I'm Stephanie Wong
and today I'm bringing back on Brian
Dorsey he is a developer advocate for
compute and we're gonna be talking about
how you should rethink your VMs which
I'm excited to hear about because I'm
unsure of what you actually mean by that
ok excellent let's do it yeah so ok
let's start by examining our assumptions
about VMs like what are some of those
assumptions to me a VM is a virtual
computer you have CPU memory this
networking what else is different
here yes that's exactly it it's relevant
though is that it's the base of many
many of our other services
it is super common in architectures
everybody's running some VMs but if
you're if you're only thinking about it
as kind of a classic VM you might be
leaving kind of time and money on the
table
Oh time and money that's like everyone
stopping money great yep ok interesting
the hearing more but I mean as I
imagined don't Google Cloud VMs
typically fit in that model so at a high
level yes it is an abstraction of this
CPU network disk Ram but we're used to
think of that as kind of a slice of one
computer and its really a slice of
resources that are across the whole data
center so that enables a whole bunch of
agility and reliability that you
wouldn't get you wouldn't notice
otherwise or you might not get I imagine
this is the basis of what you mean by
rethinking VMs slice of a data center
yeah so can you kind of dive into more
about how that's truly different than
otherwise so like an example of that is
you know you when you buy a computer
it's kind of a big decision you buy it
and you have it for three to five years
or whatever and like you're stuck with
that shape when you turn on a VM in the
cloud you're really setting the
configuration for that machine right
then and if you turn it off you can keep
the disk around that the boot disk and
then you can just turn it back on with a
completely different configuration so
you can be like oh I've got a two core
machine or now I've got a twenty five
core machine or a 250 core machine and
maybe I only want that for like an hour
or a day and that kind of thinking gives
you
a bunch of flexibility to be able to
respond to peak loads to do reports or
whatever that Nita like a big crunch at
the end of the month whatever it is
without building a lot more complexity
into the system Google is a huge company
and we have a large amount of compute
power in the data center so what's
possible with this amount of
infrastructure yeah so I think the
classic thing that people talk about is
scaling out right you've you've got one
service then you run it on multiple
machines and you can scale out really
well that's true but also I think things
have snuck up on us a little bit and the
the level that you can scale up to has
gotten just huge so you know our our
largest VMs are currently you know 416
core machines with 12 terabytes of
memory you know large disks and that
sort of thing and so the the limit that
you can scale a given machine up to you
like maybe a database is quite high and
if you and if you do keep it to one
machine you simplify things a bit I was
shopping for hard disk recently and the
largest one I could find was like 14
terabytes so you can get a machine with
almost that much memory as you know
you'd normally just buy it for discs so
yeah the this key there's plenty of room
to scale up as well and for apps that
have been around for a while scaling out
could be in a whole REO architecture or
scaling up you could just turn a dial
and it can really help solve a lot of
problems and save time money why does
scale up actually matter in this case so
some of the concrete examples are like a
database you know which can get really
complex when you start trying to short
it and that sort of thing
another common you know use case for the
really big machines as things like SMP
Hana which is large in memory database
it just has to run on one one machine so
things like that I think it just it
gives you more Headroom to keep things
running that you know you don't it's not
the time to do a big REO architecture
you know for the organization but it
does need to grow with the organization
so you can do that more easily so you
mentioned VM reboots how fast is that
actually on Google Google Cloud yeah
it's actually pretty quick so we can
start a machine from scratch boot the OS
gets your code running in 20 to 30
seconds
so for a lot of situations that is
plenty fast and and that's from nothing
there's no planning no you know talking
to another team or whatever for
provisioning is just ready to go I've
worked with VMs before and that usually
involve you know deploying the
hypervisor and deploying the VM on
VirtualBox or VMware for example a lot
of steps I can occur so is it easier
here in this case or yeah I think the
main thing is not worrying about
management of all of the machines
underneath right so you actually don't
have to worry about you know the tetris
game of trying to fit your VMs in with
the right other VMs or whether you have
space for them that's where the thing
you know that still happens but it'll
happen in the backend you don't to worry
about it all right so what does this all
mean practically you can make the
machine that's exactly the right shape
for your workload and not leave idle
you know machines running and you know
because they cost money so you can
actually make it the right shape and the
other place this plays out is when
you're running all your own stuff you're
always trying to keep the most
utilization of the hardware you can
because that's you've paid for it you
wonder is it right and if you can make a
machine that is exactly the right shape
for your workload you automatically get
the right utilization and in fact we'll
even recommend oh hey this machine isn't
getting as much uses as it could be you
might want to make it smaller or vice
versa it seems to be slammed maybe it
needs to be a little bigger yes yeah
you're kind of moving away from the
mental model of how do I make the most
use of this box that I've already
deployed and procured and paid for
versus okay I've deployed it but I can
actually backtrack and redeploy using a
different shape so I can optimize for
the CPU utilization and memory all these
other things yeah and and that's true
both it's kind of the planning you don't
have to like over commit you know early
on in a project but I think again where
it's not kind of not so obvious is the
time scales can be short too so you can
reboot it and run it for an hour in the
outer shape or a certain time of the
month or what have you so if we talked
about scale up what about scale out
cases yeah this is like the classic
sweet spot for cloud right you know
where you you have multiple computers
cooperating to do to do things right and
so we have tools built in to compute
engine to help you scale up and down
there's the thing called mesh instance
groups that connects to a load balancer
and you can either automatically or on
you
or config decide how many machines are
actually behind that load balancer so it
can be one or it can be 20 and that can
automatically scale up or down or be you
know on a on a dial you basically call
an API for any how big or small you want
it to be in addition to that there's
cases where you want to be doing kind of
batch workloads or where those machines
don't all have to be running that much
and it really helps us out for planning
if we can kind of schedule things so we
offer a very large discount on machines
that don't live that long
they're called preemptable VMs so
basically these VMs can never live more
than 24 hours per machine but they are
again 80% discount in many cases now so
you can be looking at you know like a
fifth the cost of another thing so if
you've got a batch workload or if you've
got a system with very little State on
the particular worker machines you can
save a lot of money that way let's talk
about access to the VMS so previously i
remember having to ssh into VMS rrdp
into a Windows machine and then I'd have
to save my section login info and target
the public IP address of the VM so you
know there are multiple steps and it
wasn't always straightforward no but is
this the same with Google Cloud are
there easier ways to access your VMs
here yeah or maybe you create a jump box
that's behind the firewall I hope you
get into or something like that right so
you know if you need to you can still do
all of those things right it's very
flexible and if you've got processes in
place you can keep doing them but we
also have a couple of tools to make
things easier than that so when you're
using the web console you're already
logged in and authenticated with Google
you know so you've got a user you know
who you are and you know that you have
access to that project so there's
actually a web-based command line
console that you can just click a button
on any VM and it will send an SSH key
back and forth and you can log right in
nice so that's super handy for one-off
situations or emergency things or you
know on a tablet when you're out or
whatever on the other hand you know
there's a strong need in large
organizations to keep like careful track
of like who's allowed to log in where
and automate that and that sort of thing
and there's a system called OS login
that basically delegates the who's
allowed part of it into the overall
permission structure of Google Cloud
which is called I am the yeah and so you
can basically delegate that there so
users can pick their own SSH key but the
the central group can decide who's
actually allowed to log into which boxes
with that key is this kind of making it
easier for administrators who are always
trying to manage public private key
pairings and sharing it out with their
teams and yeah how does it make it a
little bit easier I mean you could just
avoid a bunch of you know potential
mistakes or or just kind of grunt work
of you know dealing with all of those
yeah and I think on top of that you can
audit it better you can tell exactly
what the current configuration is or you
can change it on the fly alright let's
talk about disks so when I think of
disks I imagine you have a boot volume
you have additional volumes for more
storage is that how they work on
Google's cloud - or different in this
case this is another example of yes and
more yeah yes and so your models right
you know you've got these disks that you
can attach or detach between multiple
machines but they are again a slice of a
data center so the disks are actually by
default their network attached storage
but they're not attached to like some
particular machine out there they're
attached to hundreds or thousands of
machines to get the data back so you get
very consistent performance you get a
lot of ability to flex ability to change
things very quickly and it enables
features like if you just fills up you
could just make it bigger it also
enables things that are really not
obvious so normally a disk is in a
particular physical location and since
these are already spread out we've got a
mode where we actually spread the blocks
across two zones or across a whole
region and so you can have what looks
like one disk to the VM actually living
in two physical locations so you get a
whole bunch of disaster recovery kind of
crisis mitigation without actually
changing the app at all essentially what
you get is kind of the 8020 of a SAN
right you get like a lot of the features
you want APIs and base disk but in the
cloud the other thing that I think is
maybe not so obvious is that we think of
a computer is this physical box but in
in our cloud VM so the disk is really
the kind of identity right a boot disk
has the operating system in all your
software and everything and the computer
part is just what happens to be
configured currently so if you turn it
off that part all goes away when you
turn it back on we give you a new
computer right off the same disk
so that that changes the way you think
about reliability resiliency flexibility
that's right yeah so you can have
persistent storage for whatever
operating system and files that you
already have on that and then if you
decide that you want to reboot and you
want to reshape your VM for example then
you still have everything persisting
there so that's that's how it works so
you know we're talking about earlier
right it's because that disk lives on
looking fake this all sounds great but
are there any gotchas or any kind of
caveats here that we should be aware of
of course you know there's always
trade-offs in the world right of tech
and I think one of the things that's you
know not super obvious is that everybody
wants to use disks differently in the
cloud some people have tons of storage
some people want really high throughput
and the way we balance all of that out
is by actually connecting kind of like
I'm a real disk the throughput to the
size of the disk and it's not obvious we
don't think about it that way when we
buy a real disk but there's a certain
amount of storage and a certain amount
of i/o that you get when you buy one of
them right and so we kind of extend that
out through the whole platform so one of
the things that can be a gotcha
is you go to do a performance test and
you pick a small disk because you're
just doing a test right and it doesn't
work that well you know what this thing
sucks yeah and and it's important to
kind of look at the docs and pick the
right size disk for your throughput
target that the short version is that
larger discs are faster and they are a
network disk so you know that uses a
certain amount of the network which also
uses some of the CPU so the number of
CPUs kind of affects how but the overall
throughput and the size that just does
so take a look at those docks and make
sure that you size it right for the
workload you're trying to get let's talk
about a scenario where you want to take
a snapshot of VM for disaster recovery
or any other use case related to that is
it different on Google cloud because I
imagine you know you still have to take
a snapshot what can it enable you to
actually do so this is where them being
network-attached storage is huge because
we can take a snapshot without hardly
affecting the actual usage of the disk
at all and that snapshot can be used to
make a new disk anywhere in the world
globally in the same system so if you're
just trying to do straight backups or
want to make another copy of it
somewhere else for kind of reliability
redundancy reasons that's really
straightforward additionally if you're
trying to build a full-on disaster
recovery situation it might make sense
to think about the overall system a
little differently it may make sense to
have the database online and doing how
to add alias level replication maybe to
a smaller instance and then the rest of
the system may be behind one of these
auto scaling groups where it only gets
bigger to full size when it's actually
running and this this sort of thing is
something we you know I've talked to a
couple folks about like they they are
thinking oh I want to do disaster
recovery in the cloud we have 25
machines running the full thing you know
on our site or another zone yeah we need
25 machines for the disaster recovery
site and it's the obvious kind of
straightforward way to think about it
you know model it but likely you
probably only need one or two machines
running all the time and the rest of
them you can take advantage of the
flexibility and actually just make them
exist you know when you actually have a
disaster yeah and if that were to occur
I'd imagine that there is a pretty fast
ability for it to become active yep so
it's it's the same thing we talked about
earlier where you know the individual
machines are up in 20 30 seconds yeah
and they're behind the same load
balancer and so they just kind of scale
up to like deal with the new traffic all
right so we talked a lot about a lot of
things vm's we talked about load
balancers disk no rethinking VMs
entirely um what can people do to get
value out of cloud right now yeah that's
that's in fact the reason I'm excited
about this because vm's are almost
always like the the next step for people
who are getting into cloud it's closest
to the architectures they currently have
you can run almost any software they're
so they're the next step and if you're
building up that architecture it really
helps to kind of dig a little deeper on
these because you can simplify or maybe
leave whole parts of it out and still
get the same reliability or more and
more flexibility out of it so that's
where the saving time and money comes in
so I really encourage people to go to
kind of take a look at the architectures
are thinking about and connect them to
the the features we have to simplify
them and see where you can save some
time money awesome well that's great
words to end on and also I want to thank
you for coming back on the show because
I think thank you so much get insight
into just shifting your mental
model of how to think about cloud in VMs
so thanks again everyone again please
join us next time for eyes on enterprise
and we'll see you again soon
[Music]
[Music]